[Music]
our own cooking confidence coach Nanny
Bubby is back in studio thanks to
Chapman Automotive the sponsors of this
segment and today we are learning how to
make holiday goat cheese pockets for
salad I'm intrigued goat cheese I do
first I want to give you this I'm
stepping all over it sorry oh my gosh
we're in love with butter apron thank
you so much I missed getting one the
other day so just oh wrap that around
you mean so much to me I'm ready to cook
okay when we get to the goat cheese
Pockets yes pick an affirmation card to
see where we're at so these are Nanny
puppies cooking confidence affirmation
card okay I love this mine says I have
the courage to trust my intuition in the
kitchen okay so let me just tell you
okay I'm having trouble trusting mine
today because we're working seriously
with phyllo dough which already has
dried out under these hot lights so
we're gonna have to kind of work fast
it's gonna be great what you need to do
in your own kitchen anyway okay
especially around the holidays you know
a lot to prepare so run me through it
run you through it so what we have here
is filo Doda and
um what I have done is layered this was
so it didn't dry out okay layered three
of these sheets on top of each other
brushed with butter and also with
breadcrumbs so together we are going to
take one the last sheet okay here I'm
shaking I'm so nervous and we got this
it's going to be great okay as we take
this off can you tell me what phyllo
dough is I don't know you know it is a
Greek dough okay adopted by Americans of
course like we have throughout the
entire Melting Pot as we've all grown
together and it's made with flour but
most importantly like a tapioca starch
or a potato starch and then it is rolled
out paper thin as you can see yeah it's
really thin now if your grandmother or
great grandmother were Greek you
probably made your own okay but in
today's day and age why would you right
so you can buy it just keep it covered
if you can cover that for me so it
doesn't dry and so we're putting on now
the reason that you brush it with butter
is to keep it moist and also you're
going to sprinkle it with breadcrumbs in
between each layer so that they don't
stick and you've got just a crispy or
puffier more wonderful dough then here's
a nanny Bubby tidbit we're going to take
a good tidbit I love this so this is
goat cheese and when you cut goat cheese
it just crumbles everywhere here's the
tidbit stick it into the freezer for 15
minutes before you cut it okay and it
just slices oh and it still Cuts easily
I was wondering if you're gonna have to
dig it so going to put that there and
still even under these Hot Lights it got
a little crumbly but hey you're going to
forgive me because I'm sticking together
resting my intuition in the kitchen yes
we're trusting our affirmation okay okay
so help me out okay let's take a little
bit of cranberries I love them am I
putting it on this one over here over
there there we go and then we're going
to take orange zest now normally I would
take the orange zest and zest it whoops
the other hand well something like that
anyway and zest it like that but that
would take a long time and we don't have
it so let's just take the orange things
easy yeah and just sprinkle sprinkle
that okay okay and now we're going to
take this and just cut the phyllo dough
in half and then we're going to make a
pocket so
oh we're taking all of it yes we're
gonna fold that over I can't believe
it's still nice and more it looks great
I'm so happy it's our affirmation card
we put it out there that this is going
to work and we're gonna make it through
look at this beautiful little bit now
even if it Tears like it just did there
you're okay because what you're gonna do
with this beautiful pocket I'm so happy
it looks like we made it to the end here
is you're gonna brush it with butter the
better yes and especially because we
spread love like butter it's on the
apron that's why we do it and we're
going to brush it to keep it from
falling apart okay not and then you put
it on a baking dish like this and it
comes out I didn't even take this over
here you were prepared all these are
absolutely oops there we go absolutely
beautiful cheese Pockets we're going to
take them if you'll grab the salad okay
we're gonna take this and put it right
on top of the salad about another Danny
Bobby tidbit I put uh when I was testing
this orange zest on the top before I
bake a little and then it came out
um very uh Brown okay so better to do it
do it after and let's sprinkle it with
sea salt a little garnish and some
orange sections and uh start your fork
wow this look I want to just pick it up
maybe but I guess lipstick the lip gloss
and it'll get everywhere so just kill
that out amazing yeah so you can see it
all so excited to dig in look at how
great this is a beautiful Christmas meal
and in fact you could even sprinkle a
little bit of I trust my intuition so I
made it I love it I'm going to sprinkle
so you can get your cooking confidence
affirmation cards your spread love like
butter and your spatula nannybubby.com
Swagger Instagram or Facebook you can
find it there and I love working with
you it's always so great to see you
Merry Christmas I'm gonna dig in check
out Nanny Bubby's kitchen and Garden on
social media and online at nannybee.com
we also want to thank Chapman Automotive
for sponsoring the segment
20